There is a conservative, a British politician
who rung a green peace activists neck when
she interrupted a speech in the United Kingdom
a few days ago.
And I'm going to set this up for you.
Mark Field is a member of parliament or an
MP as they are known in the United Kingdom.
He's 54 years old.
He's a member of the Conservative Party in
the UK, also known as the Tories and a few
days ago, Chancellor Philip Hammond was giving
a speech about Brexit at what's called the
bankers and merchants dinner.
Greenpeace Greenpeace is the climate activist
organization.
They sent 40 volunteers to do, uh, to this
event to try to interfere with the speech
and get attention for climate change.
One woman was walking around there as part
of this protest and Mark Fields got up and
grabbed her and pushed her and then rung her
neck.
Some might almost call it strangling from
behind, although I don't know that that's
the right term in this particular case.
And there is video.
So immediately the question is, is this treatment
too rough for someone that seems to be one
of 40 peaceful protesters.
Some have argued she could have had a gun.
Hard to imagine from the dress she was wearing
that she had a gun.
Not to mention both of her hands were full
of items, which would make it quite difficult
to even get a gun out of her purse if that's
what she had.
And where she had it.
Fields is saying his reaction was quite instinctive
given the circumstances and fields has since
apologized to the woman.
There are other mps calling for this guy to
go.
Labour, MP, Tanya Antone, artsy says quote,
no one who reacts like this to a peaceful
protest should be sitting in our parliament.
Liberal Democrat, MP Chuka Umunna, uh, says
that the actions are totally unacceptable.
Former Tory MP, Sarah Wallace and says, it
was quote absolutely shameful.
A male MP marching a woman out of a room by
her neck, Labor Minister Don Butler tweeted,
this is horrific.
Mark field must immediately be suspended or
sacked.
Bottom line, a woman in a ball gown with high
heels holding a cell phone and a small purse
is not the threat that instinctively was apparently
what went to Mark Fields.
Mind here, it's extremely difficult to buy
that.
Now, some people are making this a man versus
woman issue saying, Oh, you're only upset
because the protester was a woman, but it
would've been totally fine if the protest
or had been a man.
There is no question that gender is a factor
here.
I would argue it's a reasonable factor, but
beyond that, a sitting MP, putting his hands
on a member of the public's throat is now
what we're defending.
I got an email from a viewer saying the way
this guy reacted, his entire posture, his
entire demeanor during this is of a classic
domestic abuser.
I would not argue that this guy is a domestic
abuser, absent evidence that he is a domestic
of view abuser.
What I do believe is that this is a level
of aggression that did come naturally to me,
to to him in the moment, and I can also tell
you that in the United States, far less aggressive
physical attacks than this often lead to people
being charged with battery.
So I want to hear from you.
What do you think about this?
If you've been listening to the podcast or
radio show and you, you didn't see the video
that we just played for a video audience,
find the video online and let me know what
you think of it.